j'ai pas de clients de 40 en lice plus
alors les journaux vraiment délaissé par
les lecteurs
les français et la presse c'était mieux
avant oui mais pas beaucoup plus non
plus regarder si on s'en tient au tirage
de la presse quotidienne payante 10
millions 900 mille exemplaires étaient
imprimées chaque jour en 1950 et 11
millions 900 mille en 1970 le journal
papier c'était presque une religion mais
après les années soixante dix les choses
ont commencé à se gâter les impressions
des journaux payants en diminuer petit à
petit puis ont dégringolé dans les
années 2000 pour chuter à 6 millions 100
mille tirage quotidien en 2017
beaucoup de passage qui passe devant le
kiosque mais ils passent pas chez moi
mais où sont donc passés des amateurs de
presse le premier journal en france et
pas le monde c'est pas le figaro c'est
pas l'équipe s'est pas libération le
premier journal en france le plus lu
certains gratuits ces 20 minutes 20
minutes et ses deux millions de lecteurs
quotidiens en 2004 mais aussi direct
matin et métro les journaux gratuits en
bouleverser le marché dans les années
ce métro métro un autre concurrent a lui
aussi gagné du terrain au même moment
cet internet aussi beaucoup de choses
sur internet
il faut chercher les informations en
plus parallèle différentes mais
attention les lecteurs des gratuits et
d'internet ne sont pas forcément
d'anciens l'acteur de presse payante
au contraire ils créent de nouvelles
audiences eh oui en 2004 les trois
quarts des lecteurs des gratuits ne
lisait pas le journal avant quant à
internet les éditeurs ont vite investi
ce terrain et attirer les jeunes
générations et le parisien
l'exemple parfait c'est le journal le
monde sur les 286 milles exemplaires du
journal vendus chaque jour 125 mille
sont des versions numériques quotidien
mohammedia comme le nôtre doit innover
en permanence lancer de nouveaux projets
viser de nouveaux publics
bref le numérique et les gratuits
ont-ils tué la presse certes ils ont
pris de la place il se vend moins de
journaux papier qu'avant mais tous
supports confondus
le lectorat c'est à peine effrité dans
les années soixante soixante pour cent
des français lisent un quotidien tous
les jours à peine plus qu'en 2018 avec
59% à la consulter sur papier ou en
ligne
[Musique]